what the heck is going can you write can
you play are you ready how you doing I'm
doing good man you ready for a game I am
ready to go like what we did with the
place make you feel right at home
pack her stuff on the walls I figured
that would be your gig yeah you gonna go
in the Hall of Fame as a packer or a
Raider come on you come here and you're
Mawson like yeah that's my cannot today
for a second time this season already
putting putting Charles Woodson out in
the field he was at Green Bay hanging
with the Raiders and Packers two former
teams of his in the National Football
League and he joins us back here on the
show how are you Charles Woodson man are
you I am doing great we just showed a
clip of you with Gruden he was your
first ever professional football coach
right you were his first draft choices
with the Raiders correct man he
certainly was man 1998 I was the fourth
overall pick and we got to talk about
that a little bit on the show too but
yeah it was man like my first coaching
here he is you know I came back to the
race for second time now he's back again
for a second time so it was pretty cool
to talk to him like that in that setting
yeah and you chatted with with Derek
Carr as well prior to this game at man
or man it it all turned on car reaching
for the pylon and fumbling into and
through the end zone I hate that rule
man I'm wondering what you an all-time
goat defender thanks to that rule where
the ball goes to the defense just
because it gets fumbled into the end
zone and threw it what do you think of
that rule no you know yeah I don't like
the rule at all man and I don't know you
know why there is such a rule you know
it's just funny how it seems like
sometimes things that seem so easy and
you know hear things that we think about
that should be a certain way and it
should be a simple change doesn't get
changed you know so you sit here you
know after a big game like that in a
play like that
changes the entire game you know always
laugh when people say oh well one-one
play doesn't change the game well I
don't believe that you know momentum is
a scary thing what sits on the other
sideline in that plate I was a fourteen
you know potentially fourteen point
swing where you know they're going into
score
possibly a touchdown and all of a sudden
Green Bay gets the ball back and they go
80 yards for a touchdown so yeah not a
fan of that rule certainly when you talk
about how momentum can change a game and
certainly when momentum that is
potentially game-changing is placed into
the hands of Aaron Rodgers who had
produced statistically the greatest game
in the history of Green Bay Packer
quarterbacking with a perfect passer
rating first to ever do that in the
history of that vaunted franchise use
chatted with him as well in the week
leading up same guy same situation that
you saw a happier guy tell me how you
found Aaron Rodgers when you connected
with him Charles I did man they seemed
like a guy to use his one of his words
relax he was very relaxed going into the
game and we just got a chance to talk
and I talked to him about that current
team and he talked about how he feels
like he really has some some leaders on
the other side of the ball you guys that
have come in like Siderius Smith and
kind of taken over a leadership role and
it has brought a certain energy that
team that they hadn't had in out there
in a few years and you know he really
kind of hopped on that and he said
that's that's been a game changer for
that team and I said he's you know much
more comfortable in the offense with
with Matt Lafleur you know their
relationship is starting to gel and he's
starting to understand the offense
better each and every week and I think
you kind of saw that on Sunday and you
know after the game I asked my obvious
question you know cuz last the last time
I think it was a Cowboys week he said
the Cowboys game was his best game and
so I asked him after the game and say
hey man was this your best game yeah you
know he kind of gave it a look like yeah
my best game so so yeah man he's feeling
good
especially with you know how the
deepness has carried the team you know
so to speak to this point but he's
feeling he's feeling dangerous right now
and I think the worst quarterback in the
league that you were to feel dangerous
certainly when you say that he thought
his best game was Dallas's and even
admitted this one was better than that
and he didn't have Davante Adams for
either of them
so this is this is this is not even the
ceiling right Charles would you would
you agree with that
could you repeat the risk that neither
of those games Dallas or the one that
you just witnessed he Davante Adams was
playing in neither so this is not even
the ceiling would you agree with that
for them absolutely not I think what
you're doing a game like that when you
have your top receiver out you know you
begin to find players on your squad that
you didn't know I could go out there and
make plays for you or guy that had a
limited role you know stepping into a
much bigger role go out there and make
the plays when needed Devante we know
he's a number one wide receiver but when
he's not there what do you do you know
you spread it around you look for other
guys we also talked about you know the
importance of Aaron Jones and him being
a big key for that offense to get things
going and he was another guy that had a
spectacular catch in the first quarter
of the game where he had to find the
ball at the end zone turn around one way
and then had to turn the other way to
catch the ball so he's an important part
of that that opens but yes those young
receivers stepped up
Scanlan and you know their names are so
crazy I can't even think of the names
right now that's can't looking at Kumar
oh and Allyson and was I mean it sounds
like a law firm man it's it's it's
totally frozen yes and all those guys
contributed and if you look at that game
I mean all of those guys got catches and
so you know like I said you started
finding some gems on your roster that
you didn't know you know didn't
necessarily know we're there and I'd
expect a big fall well they know now
we're also looking around Charles
Charles Woodson here on the Rich Eisen
show I had DeForest Buckner on
yesterday's show Niners are
six and oh and the Saints are six and
one because they have teddy bridgewater
keeping the the ship is not afloat but I
mean steaming towards the Super Bowl and
you just saw the Packers there at six
and one and you know what it looks like
and feel like to be around a Packers
team that's on its way to the Super Bowl
and win it all do you think Green Bay
has the ability to go into Miami and win
it all this year Charles I think without
question I think with with the Green Bay
Packers having a defense right now
playing the way it's playing I'm having
guys up front that can pressure the
quarterback and you know be able to get
to him and throw officers off in that
way have secondary have young players
like Kevin king who's come up with
another fourth-quarter interception this
type of stop a drive a big plate of
course in the game having a young guy
like Jack Alexander who all also got to
talk to a young guy that just brings a
tremendous amount of energy to the game
they they have the attitude they have
speed on defense to go out there and you
know help the team overall but like I
said with Aaron Rodgers if he was
becoming more and more comfortable with
this offense and they continue to jail
the way that they are and like you just
brought up without Davante Adams and
then you get him back and you know he's
a guy that you have to potentially
double you know out there on the field
and so if you have to duel him and you
got young players on the other side that
can go out there and carry the load if
they can't get the ball to the Ponte I
mean you got it you got a tough out with
the Green Bay Packers you know if they
get into the playoffs and I don't think
there's a question they will get in
Charles Woodson joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show and you also spoke with
Derek Carr as folks are gonna see on NFL
the grind tonight Derek told you that he
likes the players that he's playing with
he likes his teammates and even said to
you that sometimes that's not always the
case and saying that you would know that
as well I mean what what did he mean by
all of that Charles
well I think you know when you're going
to you know any season you know there's
always new players players that come
from different organizations and you
know maybe they don't have the same
beliefs in the team same beliefs in the
scheme same belief in you you know that
you had and somebody else that was there
so you may not have you know great
relationships with those guys and when
you're going out there on Sunday you
know you may not be on the same page I
think with their I think with what he
was talking about is these young guys
were all during the offseason and they
did have you know some controversy this
offseason with you know a big named
Claire that was supposed to be there and
kind of took them Charles you won't even
say his name anymore yeah not right now
right now man you know a girl news guy
to be on the team and he let us all down
so no I'm not gonna say his name right
now and so I think these guys they they
gel together as a young team and they're
young players guys I gotta get some
experience in the game together but they
went through all of that together and I
think you know they're got a chance to
you know kind of see these guys young
players you know come in and not worry
about any of that
you know they came out there to work
each and every day Grune said the same
thing I talked to mike Mayock before the
cabin he said the same thing he said
he's got guys that truly love football
and I got that from from Derek and then
also I mean I talked to so many guys
will talk to judge Jacobs and you know
talking to him and njj Eric Zander
Alexander on the other side man rich you
can tell that these guys here are that
they're happy to be in the league but
not just happy to be in the league and
so what I mean by that is they're not
just happy just saying hey yeah I'm in
the NFL these are guys that want to
leave their mark and and I think that's
what Derek Carr was getting that when
saying that he loves this group of young
guys if you watch that game offensively
they look great
and for that first half I mean like I
said they're about to go up by possibly
1740
I think at that point when you got in
there a man that kid Waller is no joke
that tight end is oh my god you exam
he's probably he's a guy I watched you
know during that game earlier in the
game I watched no Oakland going a four
by one set and they got water all by
yourself so they expect there's got to
be a matchup problem and I think Jaya
Alexander was on him and you don't have
pretty tight covers but they didn't go
there but that's the kind of matchup
you're gonna look at Waller
if you watch them during the game he had
touchdown called back I mean just this
kid that I had mind you Mitchell day but
if it weren't for penalties and that
sort of thing so they're confident in
who they have on this team and they know
they're young but they're but they're
they're they're guys that come in and
play with a level of maturity and
they're happy with where they're at
right now Charles Woodson here and the
Rich Eisen show in a couple minutes to
have with you left I wanna hit you on to
two items one of which is the
quarterback that you first interviewed
for the grind back in week two Tom Brady
our fellow Michigan man Adam Schefter
saying hey take a look at his real
estate the situation selling his house
his trainer sold the house to that just
that there's a little bit of smoke here
that he might be preparing to leave New
England or exact whatever leverage he
has in that direction do you think
that's the case Charles knowing Tom as
well as you do well you know he's said
in the house and the trainer said in the
house I think what he's probably going
to do next year is just you know they
probably moved the family down a
prisoner and they'll just commute back
and forth so I'm not gonna put a whole
lot into it right now that a Tom Brady's
retired and all of that or leaving or
preparing to leave maybe New England and
play for another team do you think that
would be possible I did you know I just
ain't rich man for the last I think for
the last five or so six years and then
we've been all speculating on what time
is gonna do we've all been speculating
on how he looks at some point during the
season that he's dropped off the ball
speculated that it's our own strength
ain't there we've all speculated that
our man
Hindman bill ain't getting along we got
all these speculations and all these
does go out there and win more Super
Bowls so I'm not going to sit on here
and try to foresee what he's doing
I feel like Brady is a guy that always
has a plan and he always keeps keep
people guessing and I think the only
people that know what he's going to do
is himself probably his wife in this
trainer and that's probably it
and all of us are sitting around here me
you talking and trying to figure out
what he's going to do he probably has an
underground lair somewhere there
somewhere there and Boston and nobody
knows and living underground and that's
where he's going to be for the
foreseeable future so I don't I don't
even I don't even worry about time and
he'll be all right
we are expecting to play 2:45 like you
said okay and then about an hour before
you you call in here everything's
popping up about our coach Jim Harbaugh
who you saw a couple weeks ago getting
into the Michigan Hall of Fame by the
way congratulations on that Charles
thank you you most welcome and obviously
deserving of it that he had to send a
letter to recruit saying that all rumors
of him trying to get pursue an exit
strategy out of Michigan quote unquote
total crap
did you get any sense being in Ann Arbor
that this this would finally maybe spin
in a direction with Harbaugh leaving
with our with us needing a new coach
Charles do you sense that at all well
well I did I didn't sense that but for
me anytime and it just isn't about coach
Harbaugh situation but anytime I ever
hear a coach have to deny that there is
a rumor of him leaving
I immediately believe it so I mean I
don't have any inside knowledge of
what's going on but if he's got it if
he's got to send out letters and you
know declare this that he's not going
anywhere in the whole nine and I you
know I don't put a whole lot into that
so I think probably there's where
there's smoke that's probably fired on
this I don't know if they they she ate
it too poking around or the NFL came
hooker I know which one it is but to me
there's always some truth to that
so when you say
okay so you believe the fact that there
is something going on not believe the
denial is what you're saying well what
I'm saying yeah what I'm saying is I
normally for that when I was there right
but what I'm saying is now that you
brought it up and then a coach has to go
out of deny it now I'm saying yeah
that's probably something there what do
you think ails the the program to the
point where I shouldn't say this because
the damn man they almost had it and that
kid Ronnie Bell needs to keep his chin
up because the Michigan's gonna need him
and he's really talented so all that
said what do you think is is going on
with with the Michigan program Charles
yeah you know it to me I mean it's kind
of hard because we could we got it we
have a talented football team and you
know I just watch the game sometimes and
just seems like there's there's just
something there that that's missing
that's missing you know I I don't I
don't feel I don't feel the type of
energy you know from the games when I
watch the games that I need to feel so
I'm not you know I'm not sure where that
derived from you know of course cuz I'm
not in the locker room and in that sort
of thing so I don't know what the
players go through on the day of the day
and all that but you know they're just
to be there seems to be something
missing um but then also to you know
when I watch you know like I watch Penn
State came and you know I watch to me I
feel like the guys a lot of times
because of the way our the way our
defense is built you know it isn't
attacking defense you know when you guys
have to play man-to-man across the board
but I feel like at times man you got to
get out of that sometimes you know you
got a maybe you line up in a bit slick
with this look but you got to get out of
there I mean because just like you watch
film on a certain team that team also
watch the screen with you
and so those teams know exactly where to
attack us on defense and I saw you know
Metellus he's sitting there lined up on
you know the wide receivers from Penn
State number one is the best player on
their team and you know in that
situation I would much rather have you
know the bird hello
one of the you know corners on that guy
you know at all the time so you know
they're just you know little things like
that and just you know just the energy
you know that that you need to go out to
and be you know the top teams you know
it's just something missing Charles
you're the best I love our chats as you
know on and off the air and I couldn't
be more thrilled every time I see that
you're on the docket to do a deep dive
for NFL LeGrande you're awesome at it I
hope you keep doing it you're great oh
man I appreciate it yeah uh I got a
couple more left in me so uh you'll be
seeing the talk to me again okay Charles
Woodson will chat soon you're the best
yeah take care that's Charles Watson at
Charles Woodson on both Twitter and
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app